the guys I thought didn't have my back
had my back many of the guys I thought
had my back didn't have my pen the
greatest filtering system in life is
when you have a massive crisis in your
life
you can immediately filter out 90 of
people in your life what types of Crisis
bankruptcy divorce loss of a loved one
it's the fastest way to filter out the
real people and the fake people in your
life immediately there's nothing like it
the cousin you thought was the best
cousin that he's been jealous for a long
time you just never revealed it until
your fault the best friend you had that
you know you thought he was like the guy
that had your back and it was right next
year like oh this is my guy no it wasn't
he's been waiting for you to have a fall
because he's internally envious of all
the attention and all this all that
you're getting he's sick of it